ses statuts elle est remplacée corps
c'est pour ça qu'on aime
cyril oui bonsoir savez que j'ai
longtemps traîné dans les couloirs au
tour avant les vraies mises sur écoute
j'ai l'impression de rentrer enfin dans
une boîte je me suis fait recaler depuis
six ans allez vous pouvez remercier
également vos petits camarades
oui donc beaucoup plus vrai oui pour que
vous intégrez l'équipe de tpm de
l'argent non pas de l'argent il en
angola ils m'ont beaucoup dit il
beaucoup dit du bien de vous et c'est
vrai que certaines longtemps que je vous
suis depuis que vous êtes avec moi dans
touche pas à mon sport c'est ça ouais
après enfin elle était avec estelle
denis law touche pas à mon sport ensuite
à la fée vous avez fait et bear grylls
est unanime et raymond c'est mon pote
vous le savez vraiment à beaucoup de
fichiers sur les réseaux sociaux dans la
rue ça que raymond eddé juste parce que
c'est mon pote je vous dis franchement
moi si vous êtes naïf c'est mon pote
voilà c'est c'est mon frérot en a on
avec vous le redis on a été chercher les
deux pouces et la table ping pong en
sommes voilà on est on a mis des trucs
dans des camions on s'est réveillés très
ensemble c'est vrai voilà c'est mon pote
des chemins épi déchaînement télé fait
venir tous ses potes intéressant énorme
mais j'adore à la télé j'ai pas la scène
qui m'a dit qu'est ce qui fait la seule
ancienne est longée poteau voilà je mets
un cliff qui suis à la merci frérot
[Applaudissements]